you have a favorite TV theme song of all
time
anything from the 60s here we are face
to face what's your favorite TV theme
song of all time TV theme song for me
it's definitely the Brady Bunch
I would have to say I'm Mary Tyler Moore
you're gonna make it after all
I think it's a friend's theme song it's
so iconic
it's a classic I would not have to do
the friends one to do I knew it you look
like a clapper Rockhopper can I say I
knows what the Fresh Prince of bel-air
now this is a story all about how my
life got flipped turned upside down and
I'd like to take a minute just sit right
there I'll tell you how I became the
Prince of a town called bel-air what's
your favorite TV theme song of all time
when I wake up full house
yeah right Oh
Smallville theme song he's gotta be my
favorite
Golden Girls thank you for being a
friend travel down back again that's my
jam I'm a Disney kid okay
I mean I'm gonna so that's so raven i
don't know if you know that one
yeah that's me
hey what's up you guys thanks for
watching ET on youtube for more great
videos be sure to click to subscribe